real-life aerial here it wasn't
everything that you wanted it to be in
Martin yes so why is it was it really
was I feel like he danced the best that
he's danced and I'm incredibly proud of
him he made so much improvement the
judges recognize that and his hard work
is only up from here I'm very happy and
very proud Bobby and Sharna dishing on
their Disney night routine and making
light of those romance rumors
the fans love you guys together what do
you attribute the chemistry to love I
like a few just laughs well we like it
you give me a love in many ways we spend
it what is this way this way if we spend
a lot of time together and if you don't
like really if you don't absolutely
think the other person is awesome you
don't kill each other but like I'm in
love with like some of my best friends -
Matt for example back home I love Matt I
love a Craig so yeah I think way to
people that from in the beginning I just
really blunt and honest with each other
and it allowed us to get to know each
other very very quickly and we've bonded
a lot I do love him yes no no that's not
why I do I love it
absolutely and I'm loving every part of
this experience not know I know she
doesn't know every word so parts are not
lovable by me with you there I'm not the
most lovable but would the radio show
host be up for being a bachelor he did
say this on a show last month
listen I'm gonna tell you if I go find
Dancing with the Stars they're gonna
offer me the bachelor I can already tell
you I heard that you said that you
wanted to maybe be the bachelor and that
if you were single after this you would
be offered it do you I didn't say I
would be offered it we never predict
that I would be offered the bachelor if
I'm still single and I go top three unde
and some of the stars I believe in the
ABC family I would be offered the
bachelor in the past someone's reached
out to me before and I said I don't know
about that but now I'm listening I'm
just living my life your prince charming
tonight tonight I'm a prince but
tomorrow I will be Oracle again so
that's
it's true every week we start with their
kids and we work it out before you for
now the pair is focused on all things
dancing I hope you guys know that's what
everyone who's gone home so far has been
a woman what do you make of that crap
that's what I'm making about crap yeah
that's bad it's just crap I won't even
say I think yeah I think it's horse crap
it's really interesting and I don't
think that that's fair necessarily I
don't understand how that happened
that's a massive coincidence that it's
been all the women that went home I said
all the dudes home except me Bobby in a
show every week on a Monday it could be
a thing don't worry Keith are you guys
worried about a double elimination
coming up since there was none tonight
yeah absolutely who isn't worried about
a double elimination that's terrifying I
mean what am I gonna do what am I do go
and worry about I'm gonna dance at best
I can dance this huh this how every week
works right we worked so hard and then I
get up and I don't do as good out here
that I normally do and then she's like
come on why don't you do so bad and then
I go I'll do better and then we do it
again so I'm just hoping that we
continue to get just a little bit better
but I won't be as good next week as I
will be in practice this week that's
just how it goes you ever want to talk
back to the judges I kind of do so but
and I stopped I talked about last week
and if I shouldn't have you guys to your
Halloween night dance really faculty
should we sing the song but not the
creepy version oh so we're for Halloween
I'm gonna be mr. Sandman and she's gonna
be my victim kind of like real life and
so I didn't really get those parallels
right yeah yeah sound like the horror
horror monster in her life right now so
and then there's that song from the
movie the 1650s it goes mr. Sandman yeah
but this is like if Nine Inch and it's
like a band but it's like Oh that'll be
awesome now we have a freestyle that's
for a freestyle we're saving that